oh she's naked wow
oh sorry
who are you i'm janet
hello mindy my name is bee i'm from the
good place and welcome to your first day
in the afterlife what's up idiot sorry
i'm late babe hey are you pregnant
that's not possible congrats yeah so
mindy look you mostly suck but then you
did this one good thing i mean i still
think we should get you they didn't but
neither did we
a compromise was made the neighborhood
you were in now by yourself you
submitted a list of things you wanted
the good place provided those things
yeah and the bad place made some
modifications we got you your favorite
beer yeah but it's always warm on your
jukebox you'll find every song ever sung
yeah by the eagles and it's only the
live versions also there's some spoken
word poetry from william shatner
it's deeply terrible you get the idea
welcome to eternal mediocrity welcome to
the media place so what's up what's your
deal you single what's going on
hi you got to help us i'm eleanor this
is chidi and see we thought we were in
the good place but as it turns out yeah
guys i know
you've been here 15 times already what
did you bring the cocaine i asked for
please tell me you somehow remembered
this time
mama needs her medicine we've met before
i'm janet i know
but no matter what you always go back
you formulate a plan to defeat michael
and you head back okay a plan
we need a plan but what if we come up
with a plan we've already tried before
will you please stop that
yeah just to help you out a little i've
written down every plan you've ever come
up with
which obviously never worked because
you're here and you're back so
good luck physically attack michael
seduce michael make michael think he's
the one in the bad place catch that
magic panda use her powers
oh i'm guessing that was jason that guy
has no idea what's going on
i know it says here that we already
tried throwing tahani under the bus but
maybe we should revisit that throw her a
little bit harder maybe under a bigger
bus what do you think
i think this is pointless we're trapped
in a warped version of nietzsche's
eternal recurrence oh cool more
philosophy that'll help us well don't
you see the problem we are experiencing
karma but we can't learn from our
mistakes because our memories keep
getting erased it's an epistemological
nightmare
ugh even your nightmares are boring dude
you were so mean eleanor you're just
like those childhood bullies who said i
would never get tenure and you are so
irritating in one of these reboots i
probably strangled you and then went to
the even worse place but you know what
i bet it was worth it oh nice
sorry can i just vent to you for a
second chidi is so
annoying i just i cannot believe that he
is the one i'm stuck here with uh-huh
wow crazy oh sorry geez man i thought
you could be human for like two seconds
and listen to me
i have eleanor i have listened to you
talk about chidi 15 times in 15
different ways let me just cut to the
chase you two
you got it bad for each other
no we don't chidi's just a friend what
am i saying he's not even a friend he's
just a weird teacher that i hate
dude i do not want to watch cannonball
run two right now
or all right what happened in the first
one so i'm all caught up
i don't know what's gonna happen to us
but i need to tell you something
i love you and you don't need to respond
cause
i know you have trouble saying how you
feel i love you too
very funny but that's obviously not real
oh that's real baby that's real nasty
yeah this was like the sixth time you
guys were here i saw you getting sexy
the previous three times so i cut a
little hole in the wall so i could tape
you
call it my looking hole
is that a camera mindy you pervert
how many times have chidi and i slept
together eight different days but like
20 different sessions and how many times
did we say
th that stuff oh only once oh god i
hated it it like really killed the vibe
for me see after i watched the porno i
made starring you i watched you talk
about your feelings to cool down it's
like anti-porn
i've only ever said i love you to two
men my entire life stone cold steve
austin
and a guy in a dark club
who i mistook for stone cold steve
austin i mean why would you show me that
i don't know
you guys are like trapped here together
i feel bad
yeah i'm rooting for you guys no there
is no us guys we basically just met each
other no eleanor
you guys have known each other a really
long time
also it doesn't matter if i told you
that or not because when michael finds
out he's failed again he'll just reboot
you
chidi janet we're leaving
i am taking this with me oh no it's my
only copy don't
[Music]
who are you derek
thanks for helping us all those times we
showed up to repay you here's a willing
sex robot and two duffel bags full of
cocaine there are wind chimes where my
ding-dong should be
[Music]
i can work with that all right you need
my backyard for what we're conducting an
important experiment you know what i
don't care in fact as soon as i started
asking the question i thought to myself
why are you asking this you don't care
about the answer do whatever you want
just leave me out of it and if you want
to talk to someone
talk to derek
i'm sure he'll be happy to see you
who's derek
don't think of derek as my ex-boyfriend
i made him so
he's more like my son
although i did make him because i was
jealous of you and tahani so he's kind
of my rebound booty call so he's your
son rebound booty call fine if you want
to put labels on it i guess he's my son
rebound booty call
but he doesn't mean anything to me
also derek never really
worked right he's a buffoon you have
nothing to worry about
how should he love thee or how deemed he
wise who would not leave him in his
wandering
oh
i didn't see you there i was just
reciting some edgar allen poe hi
i'm derek
welcome to the medium place
derek
you have mindy to thank for that
see she found a plunger sticking out of
the ground behind our house and every
time she hits it i pass out when i come
to i'm a little bit smarter and a little
bit better not to brag but i almost have
a full-grown penis now it's resplendent
and mostly functional how many times has
mindy rebooted you i don't know half a
million what she reboots me a lot
sometimes when she's bored or just needs
some alone time sometimes just for
laughs
derek
shall we head inside okay
cool
so here are the rules michael designs
the new neighborhood however he wants
the bad place gets to choose the four
new humans but
they have to be the same general level
of badness as the original four all
right no serial killers no dictators no
one who managed a boy band
michael will not get the files in
advance so he does not have forever to
plan but he can then change the
neighborhood however he wants yeah i
have about a billion objections to this
so do i good that means it's a fair
compromise so one last issue where do we
get all the other residents for this
place well my original neighborhood was
built for torture so everyone was a
demon we can't have that i say we get
them from the good place over my dead
skin suit well what other option do we
have would anybody like a medium snack i
myself will be enjoying another classy
martini don't mind if i do
i can make the people just like i made
derek are you sure yes if the judge
restores my powers in the medium place i
can do it they'll be way more advanced
than the original derrick no offense
none taken
you